so this point up we're going to unlock
the abilities of a high-end character to
showcase some of the different mechanics
we have in the
one of the new weapon modules we now
have installed is a ricochet targeting
system connected to our eyes bounce
bullets off walls and hit enemies hiding
behind cover
this is another targeting system that
will reveal enemies behind walls paired
with the penetrating rounds of our tech
shot it's a deadly combination
looks like we found some loot this is a
smart gun it's one of the more advanced
weapons in the game allowing the bullets
to track and follow their target it's
one of many different weapons players
can acquire weapons are built of modules
that allow for deep customization and
progression this way you can be sure to
find something that will suit your place
bastards guarding this round
you
[Music]
just to remind everything you've seen
and are about to see including this
particular feature about to show you is
from a work-in-progress version of the
game and may change over the course of
development let's cover ok let's try
something different
we're going to take this guy down and
connects the Wreckers to this neural
sign in the world of cyber once you are
jacked into a net where everything it
connects to through this Maelstrom
gangman we've now connected to the gang
hideouts internal network this is the
building's personnel system let's focus
on the squad containing the Maelstrom
gang or are we just connected from here
we can deploy software that affects the
whole squad for now we'll simply unlock
the ability to perform quick hacks
alright time to show off our new
high-level abilities with quick end
using the backdoor we unlock the minute
ago we'll install a virus that jams the
connection between the Maelstrom ganger
and his weapon
this will prevent him from firing
looks like he's out of the problem nice
some of you might recognize these mantis
blades we can also double jump and
bounce off of walls which makes us a
very agile fast solo
[Music]
checked out here
sweet we just found a corporate tackle
for four weapons our top of the line
[Music]
let's scan this guy and see what's going
on it looks like Royce is back and his
prey he's got an armored exoskeleton he
won't be able to get rid of him that
easily
our weapons are not dealing a lot of
damage because he's packing an
autonomous train luckily the scan we
performed earlier reveal the week's
attacking should bring the shield deck
shields down let's finish him up
[Music]
okay let's put him down and get this job
over
that wasn't the smoothest raid but we've
got the bots and Dex should be happy but
think back what would have happened if
we hadn't met with the militant or told
Royce about the agent and her plans or
just decided to buy the bought ourselves
so many options so many possibilities
and each will have consequences that
will ripple through the game world and
your story and that's just one quest